the CEO of United Airlines has just
promised that he is going to implement
Dei all throughout his company up to and
including the
cockpit how is diversity and diversity
targets working into the avat academy we
have committed that 50% of the class of
of the classes will be women or people
of color today only 19% of our Pilots at
United Airlines are women are people of
color and by the way from all the data
I've seen that's the highest of any
airline in the country white males don't
just in the cockpits also in the sea
suite at United Airlines well look at
United I'm proud of the diversity that
we actually have in our our sea Suite I
think if you look around Corporate
America correct me if I'm saying though
so I this is just based off your website
the people you list as Executives but
out of 11 people three are women I
believe one is a person of color um
that's correct um but you know in
Corporate America I think you know
that's a low bar how do you raise your
own bar well a lot of this is you know
focusing on it we have uh programs to
one of the things we do is for every job
when we do an interview we require women
and people of color to be involved in in
the interview process bringing people in
early in their careers um as well uh and
giving them those opportunities and
creating a stronger
bench
okay I don't care what this man does to
his sea Suite I don't care if he fills
it all with a bunch of lesbian pygmy
Muslim zarrian I don't I don't
care
the cockpit worries
me Dei is necessarily opposed to
Quality necessarily because what Dei
says
is we're going to make you use diversity
equity and inclusion standards to
deprioritize Merit when you hire someone
or admit someone to University or bring
someone into your Club we're going to
deprioritize Merit because we're
boosting
sex or race or sexual behaviors or
whatever some liberals have tried to
argue that Dei actually accentuates
quality and Merit that is logically
impossible because the entirety of what
Dei is is saying there are other
considerations that you should place
above Merit or candidate
quality
Dei in rest resturants means that you
value diversity more than your dinner
okay Dei in universities means that you
value
diversity more than your education
that's not good that's a little
scary Dei in the cockpit means that you
value diversity more than your life and
I do not I do I don't really
like diversity as the Liberals talk
about it I think it's a pretty dark
thing and not conducive to anyone's
flourishing I think it's just radical
leftist politics and degrading to
everyone I certainly don't don't like it
more than I like my life this is madness
this is actual
suicide Michael are you saying that a
black woman can't fly an airplane I'm
I'm sure some black women can fly
airplanes but I am certain that Dei
policies will lower the candidate
quality of the pilots and I don't want
to get on those planes luckily I don't
really fly United that much so that's
good for me but if you do uh sorry you
know I guess we should all pray that
this turns around because that uh that
won't turn out very well I posted a
Twitter poll yesterday an X poll now we
call it yesterday was Martin Luther King
day and I didn't even remember it was
Martin Luther King day until the end of
the
day I noticed that there was some anti-
MLK posting going around on social
media MLK had become kind of
controversial and so I just I said hey
do you think Martin Luther King was a
hero as I when I was growing up everyone
thought Martin Luther King was a hero do
you think he was a hero or do you think
he's overrated and I said an answer
according to your age so if you're 44
and over you know pick this button and
if you're under 44 click this button and
I chose 44 because that's the cut off
for Gen X so I wanted to see how the the
genx and the Boomers differed from the
Millennials and the Zoomers here and for
genx and the Boomers it was 50/50 which
is actually somewhat surprising to me
50/50 MLK is overrated versus MLK is a a
hero for the younger people on this on
this highly scientific Twitter poll that
you know I just put out there but it got
a zillion does a lot of people retweeted
it it was 3 to2
overrated a clear majority of the
younger people responding to that bll
said said overrated and that part I
believe I got the sense that younger
people are not as hot on Martin Luther
King as older people why is this is it
because the younger people are more
racist or something no I don't think
it's that exactly is it because they're
less educated no I don't think it's that
exactly I think it's that
we are in a a moment of major political
shift and part of that shift is we're
tearing down a lot of statues and we're
upending a lot of myths and that happens
a lot and it's happening all over the
place we live in an age where people are
tearing down statues of Christopher
Columbus in George Washington okay and
Martin Luther King is as close to a
secular Saint as there can be he is in
the the pantheon of the liberal secular
deities
at least a saint if not an outright
deity but we're not only going to be
tearing down statues of old white guys
from the 18th century we're going to be
tearing down all of the
statues we're in a an age of
debunking that's the word it's kind of a
stupid word but that's the word that is
so popular we're going to debunk
everything we're going to demystify
everything we're going to disenchant
we're going to rip up these myths and so
the Zoomers who say they they think MLK
is overrated they've got decent enough
reason to I mean there was the discovery
in recent years that the man was witness
to a rape and kind of laughed about it
uh that Martin Luther King palled around
with Communists even if he wasn't a
communist himself that Martin Luther
King though presented as a Christian
Reverend didn't really believe in the
most basic aspects of Christianity he he
denied the Divinity of Christ he denied
the Miracles it was a little complicated
aized his PhD thesis uh which you know
now is a a bigger issue because we just
booted the president of Harvard
University for that uh so yeah those are
all the knocks on him the man also did
really great things though but in the
age of debunking in the age of of uh
demystifying and disenchanting we ignore
the great thing we ignore the great
things George Washington did we ignore
the great things Lincoln did we're
certainly going to ignore the great
things Martin Luther King did and so
that would be the reason why someone on
the right might be a little skeptical of
King and then the left has hated Martin
Luther King for quite a while now
because even though King was presented
for some time as a left-wing figure now
the left is not so interested and I have
a dream that we won't be judged on the
color of our skin now the left is much
more interested in Malcolm X than they
are in Martin Luther King now rather
than seeing Martin Luther King as a
symbol of a a a major Progressive
victory in the
1960s they they see him as an impediment
to to real radical change and the left
now is far more radical than it was 10
20 30 years ago so Martin Luther King's
coming down and and people are going to
be very upset about this I you know I
don't really care one way or the other I
think the man did some great things I
think the man had some problems too and
uh you know when I when I consider
Saints I usually consider Christian
Saints you know like the Saints
canonized by the church I I'm not saying
that secular liberal culture can't
canonize some good people along the way
too it certainly have but it's just not
my point primary
focus but but it happens it happens the
great Heroes of one
age they disappear so the question now
is who who are the heroes we're going to
raise up in their place we're in a very
destructive
moment what are we going to build up in
it's in in their place if anything at
all it's because it's a lot easier to
destroy than it is to build what a great
clip now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time